rescue plan and we're hard at work to
lower health care costs
and expand access to care which we have
seen
a great need for during the spread of
this pandemic
on tuesday we will observe the 11th
anniversary of the passage
of the affordable care act at that time
and since i've said
that that was a great pillar of economic
and health security
for the american people on a par
with social security medicare
and medicaid and the affordable care act
in this rescue plan we have some
initiatives to expand the affordable
care act
and that's why i'm so pleased to be
joined by three of our colleagues
uh representative underwood will talk
about provisions
in the bill well she will talk about
them and i want to salute her
for her success and getting provisions
in the bill
that expand the affordable care act
representative craig has been
at work on initiatives uh to improve the
affordable care act
uh but will have her own words to say
about rescue and where we are and
representative alecia fernandez she is a
freshman member
and she will uh she will have her
presentation on this subject she has
been such a leader
in new mexico on everything to make
the future better for america's working
families you'll hear from them
momentarily before that though i just
want to say
how exciting it is for us that 11 years
have gone by and there has been
a broad acceptance of the affordable
care act
it was a transformational law that
expanded coverage
lowered cost secured life-saving
protections
for american no matter how they get
their health care
coverage of course our goal is to have
universal coverage universal access to
quality affordable
health care and with a giant step
forward with that was the affordable
care act providing life-saving
protections
for more than 130 million americans
with pre-existing medical condition
and actually they can said being a woman
was a pre-existing
medical condition the affordable care
act took care of that
as a mother of five i was told that i
that was an obstacle to my getting
insurance because
i had five children and i said i thought
that was a sign of my strength
that i've done insurers from putting
limits on health care guaranteeing
essential health benefits
and free preventative services insurance
ensuring that young people can stay on
their families
policy until 26 extending health care
coverage to 20 million americans
people make a big fuss as do i about the
fact that 20 million more people in our
country
had access to to health care 20 million
people
but the fact also is that over 150
million
families had access to better health
care
at lower cost and again with benefits
like
no pre-existing condition barrier to
access to health care
but that was just one of the further
benefits
and we're proud to celebrate this
anniversary and i
look forward to make it even making it
even stronger the american rescue
plan takes both steps uh forward uh
making health care more affordable and
access accessible
and including for those who have lost
courage
coverage through no fault of their own
again when we had our campaign in 2018
and 2020
for the people one of that for the
people who would lower health care costs
by lowering the cost of prescription
drugs and preserving pre-existing
conditions
among others and the democrats will take
further
action to make this more affordable
remember we chose that name very
carefully affordable
care act well patient protection
and affordable care act a person who
has been a leader from the start in the
congress to make
the affordable care act more affordable
person who has served in the obama
administration
as well as as being a healthcare
provider herself
making a big difference here right from
the start congresswoman underwood of
illinois
[Music]
thank you speaker pelosi i am thrilled
to be here today
to celebrate the historic expansion of
the affordable care act that is now law
thanks to the american rescue plan i
represent the 14th district of illinois
and i spend a lot of time listening to
my community
what i found over and over and over
again since i took office
over two years ago now is whether i'm at
a farm
or a restaurant or at a town hall people
are being crushed by their health care
costs
throw in a pandemic and it's just been
devastating for families
while republicans have worked
breathlessly for two years
well since i've been here for two years
but for years before that
to take away health care house democrats
senate democrats and the biden harris
administration have all been loud and
clear
no family should be without affordable
care
especially in a once in a century health
crisis
and i'm here to tell you today we've
delivered for the american people
the american rescue plan included my
legislation
the health care affordability act which
lowers out-of-pocket insurance costs
and caps premiums for everyone it
requires that
americans pay no more than eight and a
half percent of their income
on health care premiums and provides a
larger tax credit
to nine million people who receive
financial assistance
helping them afford coverage through the
marketplace
those whose earnings are 400 percent of
the federal poverty level which is
slightly more than 51
500 per year for an individual
will be able to receive aid to purchase
affordable health care coverage
the cost of health care has been keeping
millions of families from thriving
but that's about to change with the
american rescue plan health is on the
way
the biden harris administration
estimates that four out of five
enrollees
will be able to find a plan for ten
dollars a month
people with the lowest incomes and
people who receive
unemployment compensation this year may
not have to pay
a monthly premium couples earning more
than seventy thousand dollars could save
one thousand dollars per month on their
monthly premiums
a family of four making ninety thousand
dollars will see premiums decrease by
200 per month and an individual making
19 000
will not have to pay a monthly premium
that's
real significant savings for hardworking
families
so thank you madam speaker for including
my legislation in this historic package
and helping me put money back in the
pockets for my constituents
everyone's had an incredibly hard year
and i'm so glad that with your
leadership
we were able to build on the affordable
care act and deliver on our promise to
lower health care costs for the american
people
thank you now i'd like to invite
congresswoman angie craig
thank you so much representative
underwood and madam speaker as always
thanks for having me here
especially during these challenging
times we're reminded
every single day that americans
deserve access to high quality
affordable health care
this is especially uh personal to me
as i grew up for a portion of my own
childhood
without that reality of having access to
health insurance
and i still remember that box of bills
that piled up for my mom who was raising
three kids mostly on her own
on the kitchen table after my little
sister went to the hospital
so i know firsthand if health care is
not affordable
it is not accessible for years in this
country
families in minnesota and across the
nation have struggled with the rising
costs of health care
i ran for congress in 2016. i lost
and then in 2018 i came back
and i ran in a cycle and served in a
session where we were here to find real
common sense
solutions to this nation's health care
issues in a 2018 the election cycle that
first brought me to congress
democratic candidates all over the
country were sent to washington
after making that simple pledge if
elected
we would work tirelessly to stabilize
and enhance
the affordable care act lower the cost
of prescription drugs in this nation and
the out-of-pocket healthcare cost
for families last year i helped pass
h.r 1425 that was my bill the
reinsurance bill
that became the base of our broader
patient protection and affordable care
enhancement act
legislation that included provisions to
significantly
increase subsidies for middle and
low-income families
making health care more affordable and
accessible for millions of americans
congratulations congresswoman underwood
for that aspect in the american rescue
plan
finally allow medicare to negotiate drug
prices and extend
many of those cost savings through hr3
to private plans as well expand coverage
to millions of americans by encouraging
holdout states to take advantage of the
federal government's medicaid
expansion and crack down on junk plans
that endangered americans access
to high quality care while strengthening
protections for pre-existing conditions
last year we came together to pass that
legislation
responding to our constituents request
to protect
and strengthen their health care my
constituents are fed up
with the years of sabotage of the aca
and the politics of division they just
want us to strengthen and make health
care more affordable
and today with the anniversary of the
aca next week
we have the opportunity to continue
these efforts with
the biden harris administration so with
that
i'll hand things off to representative
fernandez
good morning thank you so much
congresswoman and thank you so much
madam speaker
uh for inviting me here today um so
we know that this pandemic's tentacles
have
infiltrated every single aspect of our
communities lives
it put a spotlight on the work that we
still need to do to make healthcare
affordable
and accessible for everyone
everywhere and every community urban
and world in new mexico one of the
things that i did was help
build rural health clinics help build
clinics
in indian country and uh in fact
uh the uh second gentleman visited one
of those health clinics on wednesday
to look at their marvelous vaccination
plan uh
in new mexico the kiwa health clinic so
a
big shout out to that but because of
my work helping build health clinics
this issue came up over and over again
by new mexicans
they wanted congress to address the
cost of healthcare to make sure it came
down and to make sure that it was
accessible
the brilliance of the american rescue
plan is that not only provides us with
the resources to beat the pandemic
it has allowed us to expand access to
health insurance
lower the cost and gets us a step closer
to ensuring
that health care is a right not a
privilege for
all americans we've called this plan
a lifeline that's exactly what it is
and we want everyone to know that they
can take advantage of the special
enrollment period that is running now
through may 15th there are more than
14.9
million americans who still don't have
health insurance
and now can get it many current
enrollees can receive
additional financial support to get
coverage at a price they can't afford
thank you for getting that done all of
the democrats we need to thank them i
need to tell you as a freshman
it is marvelous to be able to come to
congress and get
stuff done with the democrats um
so i want to urge all americans who are
currently uninsured or
underinsured to please visit
healthcare.gov
and take advantage of potentially lower
premiums and lower out-of-pocket costs
in new mexico our hearts broke
over the devastating and deadly
impact that this pandemic had
on our native american communities many
of the tribal leaders and elders we have
lost
and the impact on the latino communities
having access to health care should not
depend
on your zip code it should depend
on your employment it shouldn't depend
on your income
and it shouldn't depend on your race the
american rescue plan
takes us one step closer to making
health care as a right available
for every american thank you madam
speaker
as we observe the 11th anniversary that
which will be tuesday
you can just see the pride we have not
only in that legislation
but in the newer members of congress who
have taken up the cause
and made their mark on this they
because they listened to their
constituents
and prioritize this health issue which
is a health issue
and an economic issue for families
because
of affordability so thank you so much
to congresswoman underwood for the
specific language in this legislation
you talked about it when you run as your
motivation for running and we're all
moved by that and then you acted upon it
at every step of the way so thank you
for your effectiveness
in this effective from the start as is
congresswoman angie craig uh with her
very important legislation that's part
of of what we did last year which we
hope will be part of what we soon we
it will be part of it but we hope that
that will be soon thank you
uh you didn't even talk about your four
sons and
they're all under 26 too there you are
[Laughter]
thank you and again to congresswoman
fernandez
uh talking about our native amer uh
indian country
i i want to join in and acknowledging
the
biden harris administration because one
of the
sticking points that we had previous to
their taking office was
addressing the inequality of access to
health care inequality to testing
tracing treating
vaccine etc and president
biden has made this a very high priority
and has has the vice president hence the
second gentleman visiting
uh the location now in our bill
it's 20 billion dollars for tribal uh
governments as well as uh another six
billion dollars for health benefits
others
in there and there so thank you for
making sure that those priorities were
addressed
in the substantial way that they were so
you can see why we think
uh that the celebration of the
affordable care act
is greatly enhanced by the passage of
the
rescue package as it takes us
forward on this subject are there any
questions
on health care and how we go forward
well again i want to thank the president
and the vice president
as well as all of our colleagues uh for
those who were here for the affordable
care act though has
those who are have fought for it been
and since even if they weren't here at
the time
and those who are enhancing it and
making it stronger again
a pillar of our america's family
security
social security medicare the affordable
care act
martin luther king said of all of the
inequalities that exist that one
the inequality of health access to
health care
is the most inhuman he used that word
huma in human
because people could die and that
inequality is something that has been of
the highest priority for us
i thank our colleagues for their
leadership you're welcome to stay
i know they would join me in
acknowledging the sadness that
our country has experienced with the
assault on the aapi
community when we leave here we will go
to the floor for a moment of silence the
flags are at half staff
as an acknowledgement but and a comfort
but it is not a comfort
unless we can end the
the fear and the injustice of it
all i'm so proud that the president and
the vice president
are visiting georgia perhaps they're on
their way as we speak maybe they're
there now
to console but also
i want to recognize that the president
early on when he made his speech to the
nation
about covid he talked about aapi
uh anti-aapi violence in our country and
how it had to
stop and he called upon the attorney
general the department of justice
to address this issue so long before
atlanta we have known that this has been
a challenge
um really exacerbated by some of the
language of a previous administration
and unfortunately last year the total it
was
over something like 3700
acts of violence against the aapi
community
that would be more than 10 a day
as a representative of san francisco i
take great pride
in representing the aapi community it's
a
blessing to us all and again we see
firsthand
the risk that it's there and something
that we are all very proud of
uh our aapi community uh we're very
pleased this week that we were able to
pass
legislation much of it coming from the
judiciary committee
mr nadler i deserve some credit a great
deal of credit for that
but a lot of the women as you see the
women are leading the way on these
issues uh uh the first um
we had the era the passage of the era
removing the barrier
under the leadership of jackie spear and
we're proud of that
uh their barrier is not in the
constitution
it was put in by the congress congress
can take it out
next we had the violence against women
act this reauthorization
in a way that is stronger in fact
listening to some of our friends
in indian country who have suffered so
much
uh from the injustice of uh violence
against women on the reservations
and no recourse and then uh that was
the other day yesterday we had the two
bills
that i'm so excited about the dream
dreamers act you may recall that uh
in the last congress i spoke for eight
hours and six minutes
in support of the dream act i won't do
that now
i didn't do that yesterday but i did use
my time to take pride
in the dreamers and what they mean to
our country
and that was under leadership of lucille
robert aller and
the promised part of it under the
leadership of
nydia velazquez and and uh also
yvette clark and new york so each up uh
we're very excited about that
legislation right now on the floor we're
taking up the
uh the uh the medicare
bill that was necessary because of the
because of the rescue package similarly
as was necessary after the passage of
the republican tax scam
we'll see if we'll they'll vote for it
to protect
medicare as we voted for it even though
we disagreed
with the tax scam didn't vote for the
bill but voted for
the protection uh when we come back we
will be
we're having committee meetings next
week to prepare for our agenda for when
we come back and we'll be taking up
apropos of the conversation today the no
ban
the repeal of the muslim ban legislation
we have legislation for access uh to um
access to uh council
the no ban judy choose legislation the
access to capital jayapal a council
major paul the women are just
ruling the roost here i mean it's just
wonderful and then we will have other
legislation as well so if you have any
questions about that yes sir oh about
this specifically
yeah i have an unrelated question okay i
have an unrelated question i'm related
to health care
anything for health care no
then you're welcome to stay
[Laughter]
but we do have votes on the floor so i i
don't know how long i can stay
yes sir um roughly a third of your
caucus
is co-sponsoring a resolution um
introduced today by congressman
jimmy gomez to expel
congressman marjorie taylor green from
the house i'm wondering where does
uh house democratic leadership stand on
that resolution and do you think that
uh congresswoman greene should be
punished further in any way
i'm not going to get into that it was a
members are very unhappy
about what happened here and they can
express themselves the way they do
what mr uh gomez did is his own view
and that is not a leadership position
yes sir i'm wondering how you think
the problem on the border if you have
any updated views on that and what the
administration
should or should not be doing i think
that the administration
is pulling this thing under control and
i think it's important to know that
the the difference between the attitude
toward the people
and the children is so different in just
these two months
versus what happened in the past four
years
in the spring as my colleague
congressman escobar has said
represents el paso and the spring more
people do
pump so there will be more as there are
now but they have to know as the
president has said
don't come and how can we address the
challenges
in their country so that they stay home
but since they are coming
they fall in different categories and
the administration is as has plans in
place to take care of the children
in a much more humane way than before
and that means that we have to have more
facilities more beds and the rest
uh until we transition these children uh
to their of
nearly half of say 40 some percent of
them
have a parent in the country that we our
country that we can
transition to closer to three quarters
of them
have a family member if not necessarily
a parent
in the country that we can transition
them to but they go from the
border patrol and then they go to the uh
what's called orr the organization the
uh refugee release and then
transition out so that that is being uh
with the fema at the border and the rest
their
the administration is addressing the
immediate concerns
it has to be though the recognition
that covet is playing a role
in how people need to be separated and
so this
adds to the challenge when more people
come
and we had like 13 thousand beds as
congressman delauro
under whose uh labor hhs committees
over our falls there's thirteen thousand
beds but when you need the space
you need more space so we need more uh
uh locations
the um i i always like to quote
the uh evangelicals they have been so
excellent on immigration for such a long
time
we are not in a hundred percent
agreement on all aspects of it but
by and large uh they have been a very
positive force
for good and when uh we were
four years ago having a brump hearing
because we weren't in the majority rump
carrying
on banned overturning the ban
that the president had put the muslim
ban whether we had the military coming
in and saying this is bad for national
security
whether we had the diplomats a thousand
of them signing a letter saying this is
bad for our national security and
whether we had the business community
saying this is harmful message to the
world
whatever it was but the message i want
to focus on
is when the evangelicals testified
their representatives said that the
united states refugee resettlement
program
is the crown jewel of american
humanitarianism
and this is part of what is at the
border is our refugees applying
for asylum in our country we had hoped
and we can reinstitute some things that
were taken down
by the trump administration to have some
of that adjudication
happen in country so that the case can
be
resolved there but there is no question
and i've taken delegations
to central america that corruption
uh violence crime
and just so many even
climate we saw the climate causing the
drought
causing the farmers to have no way to
farm the land
contributed to some people coming north
so to the extent that we can help solve
some of the problems
at home and instead of canceling that
investment
which the trump administration canceled
the investment
that we had to do just that i wish you
could see the impact of what usaid
can do to help children in those
countries so
so that is to back up again and say that
biden administration has this
under control it will take so it is
changed
and it will take some time but it is
values based humanitarian and its
aspects
pragmatic and how to with a plan to get
things done and um not just a
diversionary tactic on the part of the
republicans because they are bankrupt of
ideas on how to improve the lives of
american people
they run to the border do you anticipate
any role for congress
in addressing that situation
specifically whether it be more money
for those northern triangle countries or
more assistance for hhs i mean
do you see a specific role for congress
well we had 250 million dollars
in for the northern triangle northern
triangles
of salvador guatemala and uh honduras
and that's what when we went there
previous uh
um podell led by the chairman of the
foreign affairs committee eliot engel
one he was there they cancelled
that money but that was problematic so
in order to keep people home we have to
address the root causes
of the migration and and
that's not a big price to pay to have
the impact
that it will have and i wish as i said
earlier you could see the impact of
usaid
and organizations not that he was they
were fully funding
but they were helping they gave an
infamous tour to attract other
other support and other institutions are
devoted to
justice the justice system in those
countries
so yes it will take some resources
a small price to pay for people to stay
home
there are cases of well-founded fear of
persecution
in terms of the personal security of
people
and this is an issue that i've worked on
for my whole time in congress
and and uh that's harder uh they have
families that
well it's it's it's so sad to just
describe the situations that
families found themselves in hence moms
taking their daughters
uh north uh how we can deal with that
in some cases these children were in
places that were safe havens for them
that we
helped fund not completely funding but
helped fund
so yes there's a role for that and as i
said
orr falls under the jurisdiction of rosa
doloros
commit madam chair of the whole
appropriations committee but
orr is in uh is in labor hhs
and and they are paying very closely and
the chair of the homeland security
subcommittee
uh lucille robert allard the author of
the dream act
uh she has been working on this issue
for decades
in congress and uh again shares the
values
understands taxpay the the fiscal
soundness that we have to execute
but also um strikes a a balance in all
of it
so i'm i'm i think we're to the extent
that congress will be involved we have
experienced
hands um yeah yes chad
about 10 months ago we started to
implement remote voting proxy voting
here
was the pandemic there were concerns
about doing that
what do you see going forward about a
when congressional operations start to
return to normal
and b is things like remote voting and
hybrid hearings
will continue once the pandemics have
stopped well
one of the most um substantial steps
that can be
taken is that everybody should be
vaccinated
right now according to what i saw the
republican leader say and was quoted in
the press
that 75 of the members are vaccinated
that is not we need a hundred percent of
the members
vaccinated because uh it just takes one
uh to endanger others the uh i'm ex
much of what is happening here some of
it relates
to january 6 that's for sure in terms of
security
but most of the isolation and separation
that we have
most of the reason that we cannot have
official visits
most of the reasons why we cannot open
up as much as we would like to for
visits
for tourism etc and we hope that will be
soon
is because of covet not because of
january 6.
i mean we have our plans we are
preparing our supplemental the
general honoree has made suggestions etc
uh as you know today this the peripheral
the outer
fence is going to start to come down so
that part of it
is is being addressed but covid
is the villain covet is a villain to our
economy
unless we crush the virus we're never
going to get our economy back
cobit is the villain here unless
everyone is vaccinated
mass squares honor separation the rest
will still be at the mercy of that
hybrid
do you see that lasting after the
pandemic ends well
it's not going to end until we take it
one step at a time we still have
now today maybe it started yet last
night i don't know but
by today was hoping that many many more
staff will be vaccinated it's still not
enough
we still haven't gotten enough vaccine
but
uh enough for people to choose to come
in if they don't still if they can be
vaccinated and still want to work
from home uh if we're not insisting if
you're vaccinated you have to come in
but they don't want to come in unless
they are vaccinated and unless others
are vaccinated so
don't uh underestimate the power
of that so it's no use talking about
when unless people are willing
to get vaccinated in my view the sooner
the better
specifically are you giving your members
instructions to get vaccinated do you
think that mccarthy needs to do the same
on the republicans well you can't tell
anybody to do anything
at least of all around here but the fact
is
is that there's no
requirement it is a suggestion by the
cdc to get vaccinated
and so we're suggesting that
if you want shorter time like some of
the republicans say to me
why can't we have reduced time on the
votes i said we can
the more people who get vaccinated the
shorter we have
time we have to stay on the step
separated on the floor
so it's not something that we can
require it's something only that we
can suggest and make a readily available
which it is so thank you
we've been following the progress of
that we're wondering whether there's any
loss to the states
about controlling their own voting
regulations that they can tailor
if we impose a federal voting congress
a federal elections uh uh
can uh are this voting rights act
that's part of hr1 it's a an offspring
of it but
part of that uh yes requiring commission
voting we're very proud
of hr1 we think it is the constitution
of the united states we think it
represents the democracy of our country
by reducing which is our responsibility
to roll a big dark special interest
money in politics by removing obstacles
of participation
uh to uh the first 300 pages of hr1
are written by john lewis the first 300
pages we remove
voter suppression and you see how
necessary it is
when you see that but over 40 states
have over 250
laws now that they're striving to pass
to lower voter participation i used to
be
chair of the party and our
glory of it all was to engage people to
vote
whether they were democrats republicans
independents we
could not it was not our charge
to ask it was only our responsibility
to register people to vote and to see
the opposite of that we're a republican
party which cannot prevail on the
strength
of its issues and tie this anti that
antibiotic
but only can win by suppressing the vote
and they know that and that's why
they're doing it so no i
have no concern respectful
of where those uh responsibilities lie
i have great confidence in hr1 i thank
john sarbanes and the author of it all
for over a period of time so loft in the
chair of the house
administration committee for her
leadership so proud of all of our
members
the american people know this is a way
to steal
restore integrity by reducing the role
of big
dark money which suffocates the airways
with misinformation
rather than having a uh respectful
execution of of our process thank you
all